de nos aînés merci madame boitant la
parole est à monsieur didier contant
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur communiste qui a dû
nous quitter
donc je la pose en son absence à
monsieur le ministre du tourisme les
conséquences des attentats avec la
poursuite de l'état d'urgence l'emploi
de l'expression état de guerre
les grèves à répétition les
manifestations violentes
les pénuries d'essence les intempéries
avec les inondations ont dissuadé
beaucoup de touristes étrangers de venir
en france alors que le conseil de
promotion du tourisme présidé par
monsieur laurent fabius avait fixé
l'objectif ambitieux de 100 millions de
touristes étrangers par an dans notre
pays
le département d'état elle foreign
office ne nous épargne pas à comme les
médias étrangers qui se font l'écho de
la pagaille qui a régné et règne en
france pour reprendre la formule de
l'une de vos collègues ministres
à titre d'exemple les hôteliers
parisiens ont vu en mai 2016 leur taux
de fréquentation chuter de plusieurs
dizaines de points
c'est ainsi qu'au premier trimestre le
nombre de touristes japonais a baissé de
56 % à paris en ile de france 2 24% pour
les italiens de 35% pour les russes et
de 14% pour les chinois j'ajoute que les
réservations pour l'été 2016 sont assez
nettement inférieure à celle de l'été
dernier et cela pour la plupart des
destinations touristiques de france
ce secteur qui représente 7,3 pour cent
de notre produit intérieur brut
avec quelques trois cent mille
entreprises et plus d'un million
d'emplois et donc touché de plein fouet
c'est pourquoi monsieur le ministre je
vous demande les mesures urgentes que le
gouvernement entend prendre pour venir
en aide à toute économie touristique et
surtout pour reconquérir l'image de la
france auprès de la clientèle étrangère
notamment par le biais d'atout france
merci la parole et à monsieur matière ce
fait qu'elle secrétaire d'état chargée
du commerce extérieur de la promotion du
tourisme et des français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
didier quentin que
cherche du regard nous avons eu
l'occasion de parler et de travailler
ensemble sur le tourisme y compris dans
votre département
en septembre dernier à l'invitation du
maire et conseiller départemental de
marennes mickaël vallet aujourd'hui il
ya un contexte particulier suite à
différents événements que vous avez
indiqué qu'il faut d'ailleurs pas mettre
sur le même plan
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui de chiffres
officiels nous pourrons communiquer des
chiffres officiels après la saison
estivale mais c'est vrai que les
tendances sont contrastées nous
constatons au niveau national une baisse
d'un peu plus de 5% des nuitées de la
clientèle étrangère
c'est environ 20% sans doute sur paris
et sur sa région c'est en revanche en
moyenne dans les autres régions une
hausse de 2% dont vous voyez une
situation qui est contrastée difficile
il s'agit pas de le nier mais surtout à
laquelle il faut répondre
jean marc ayrault avec lequel nous
suivons ces sujets et martine pinville
réunira la semaine prochaine un comité
spécifiquement destinés aux
professionnels du tourisme pour faire le
point sur les mesures
vous savez que nous avons abonder le
budget d'atout france pour faire des
campagnes ciblées envers les pays où la
baisse est la plus forte sur les réseaux
sociaux que je rencontre dans chacun de
mes déplacements
les professionnels du tourisme qui font
les tendances dans les pays qui sont les
prescripteurs que ce soit à l'étranger
ou que ce soit au quai d'orsay nous
sommes totalement mobilisés là dessus
concernant le japon c'est là que la
baisse est la plus forte et nous sommes
mobilisés à ce sujet la chine est un
autre sujet sur lequel nous travaillons
je me rendrai en octobre à macao où la
france sera l'invité d'honneur d'un
grand forum international sur le
tourisme mais nous sommes en train de
préparer les délégations les clientèles
américaines reviennent et sur ce sujet
qui concerne pas un mais deux millions
d'emplois dans le pays et 8 % de la
richesse nationale
croyez à la détermination totale du
gouvernement